[Music]
[Music]
today we will cover
the framework called warp
and
warp is dependent or is built up
on
the runtime called
um a tokyo so i guess you so am i there
more
run times in the rest like world but i
think the two most um famous ones are s
inc std
and
tokyo and my guess is in the rust shop
you might
take on in the next few months or half a
year i think that tokyo is sort of like
the standard now i think that many
companies chose
tokyo in the past and this might
change and they might choose um this
this runtime here so um
but for now i will
cover warp
which is based on tokyo and i'm a tokyo
uh yeah and warp just runs on
on on emma tokyo
so to get started i created basically
an empty
like
um
like a new project i called it live code
december and if you go um into it
you will see the basic
bare bones
and for every project
to get started you need to
[Music]
you need to add a few
dependencies and and for warp that's
basically the framework itself and it's
the runtime
and like no matter which framework
like you choose you basically go to the
github page and check like which
requirements they have each
web framework you probably have to imple
or
add
at
the run time as well
and after you've done this
we just copy paste just to see if we've
done
everything in the right way
so here is basically the
the
the how you say it well like
the starter
example
and
what um warp is using in the background
for its hdp implementation
is
is a great called hyper
which brings the http
server up in the background so um behind
the warp serve here
oops
is actually
here we go
is actually the http server called hyper
and
and
the function called run is returning a
future that's the reason why we need
like a runtime so we can have an
asynchronous function and await the
future so it's getting actively pulled
from the runtime and we have a simple
first route and we will go into the warp
filter systems as well so here
we have our
let's see if we are still in there
live code
i think i changed it
here we go
so we start the server
and we can basically curl
the first example
and what we have here is
we create a path called
called
hello
and we expect a parameter which is a
string
so we have a path which is hello
and then we can pass a string which
could be
my name or your name
and once the compiling is done
we can see oops
we can see here
the server is up and running
we send a get request and we get back a
hello bastion
and why we get this back is
because on the serve
we path our
we pass our first path
and we take the string
and we print so the format um
can is basically
um yeah like a macro
just like print
ln
but it's um yeah
but it's often time like used to return
a string
and here
because
we use a rust or like a warp
filter here and how warp filters work is
they expect a certain
return type
in this case we can
return a string and warp them like knows
how to handle this string and we take
the
like the yeah the string
a parameter and we give it a name
called name
and we basically
return this string here
if you would this to change
let's say hi too
and you see the first little downside
here oops
if you come
[Music]
from a language like node.js
now the server would like recompile in
the background here
we have to stop and we have to re
recompile the application and start
from fresh
which takes like not as long as in the
beginning but we curl this again and you
see
here's our changed string let's say hi
too it's a bit
weirdly formatted
but
um
that's basically
the first
10 minutes into your rust journey um
let's say you join a company and you
want to find out or maybe you find out
the framework they are using in
production and i would always recommend
to check out the github page create your
own little
like example project and play around
just with the basics and try to change a
few things
and from here like that's not very
scalable
like the whole thing but let's try to
form
an api which we could use sort of in
production i say sort of because we
probably don't cover in the next 50
minutes
each of the edge cases
like you might face but to give it
like a bit
of a structure
um
and how warp is working
it's using
like a filter system like it's
like it's nothing you need to know from
the start it's more like
it figured out like this is the way they
want to go and their
base idea behind the whole thing
is its
filters
which means an incoming request is
getting
passed
um into here so like you start a server
you open up the port
and once like a request comes to the
like to the linux
socket on a disk port
this http request arrives and from there
like warp is sending the http
request to a set of filters to
either add a few
data points to figure out like the path
and once this matches a path it calls
dnad
the the underlying
function
so
but this here is basically a shortcut
this macro here
is a shortcut
and now let's see if i can
find
so let's see let's go to the docs
um you have
the filter system
and you have path
and you have the like the shortcut here
like the macro path but you can also do
path get or path post put
um i just have to figure out under which
this is um
filters no no no no
it's a post
oh yeah it's
it's
just under here it's not path
it's you have
for example path get
and then i have to check of how it
actually works so you have path get and
then
[Music]
you say and
and let's remove
these pieces here
and then you basically open up a path
so
you would have here path
and let's say the path is hello
and then you would say path
end
and then you would pass the route
handler here
so
we can call this function hello
and hello is not there yet
so we create
an
sync function called hello
it doesn't take much and now the
question is what should we
return here and i have to say here the
docs are
not super super simple
my way to go
like would be to go to the like examples
and see like what the route handler
actually has to
like return
and i think you will see an example
i don't know if you will see an example
at least for me it's good to know like
what actually is the
signature so you would
return
[Music]
like a result
and you he either have a reply or a
rejection
this is how
the route handler
signature looks like
and where's the problem
yeah right
so we can say here
this is not right we need
to okay it
and we need to
return a warp reply
i think this is it
no it's on okay
enough
okay
so let's see if this works now
now you can see that this is quite a
more of a complex
solution
it's longer and now
we are missing a feature
which is passing like a query
a parameter
and in case you have any question feel
free to ask them
and
in the chat
so
we can start this again
we send a curl and we get back a hello
world
so
like that's great but we actually wanted
to pass a name too
and
how this can work like the longer
version
is
you can get um
is it
and we have to check here again was it
path
param
yep
and i think you can do string
probably not like this
um
maybe like this
hmm
i always have a little cheat sheet
oh yeah right of course
um
why doesn't this work
path param string
oh that's okay
okay it didn't
save yet so now i'm warp with a vorp
emma tells us
um
that we added like a parameter
to
to the um
to the function but the function
doesn't like expect one yet so
so here
and this is why i find like the base
example like a bit like misleading for
your
for your
for your future like endeavors with warp
and here
you can see like the filter system in
in yeah like in full force like we pass
in
like the route
so and each http
request which arrives
at the like at the hyper http server in
the background
it will send through
the warp
filters
and it checks and is this a get request
check
is it on the right path so here
on the
curl we send to slash
hello
so check
and now
this filter like expects a parameter so
if we would send the same
curl
we would get like a 404 back
and then the path
yeah like is ending so like we basically
constructed
the path
like what we expect from this api call
here and then we pass the request onto
our route handler and here we see that
we need to pass a parameter
which is a string
and now it says it's basically
not used
but we can do this here now again
and say we pass param
and now it's used
then we save it
we restart our server
and now we can see
what happens if we send
the same
like one again
we see here like nothing happens we get
like nothing back
and on the left side here on the server
we don't we don't have logging or
debugging so
now
we have no idea like what was the
what was the answer of this call
and we can say like the parameter
is bastian
does this work
yeah and this works and we get back
hello bastian
but what happens if we like want to pass
actually like a
like a query
and not a parameter
so
we can say
query
and here
let's see if like if this works
if we
do this
and we have to restart the server
again
invalid
query string
beautiful so somehow this doesn't just
work
and for this we can
again check
and warp and see if
if it tells us
something helpful
for example
here like it's using a hash map for the
query
but it doesn't
seem to do this
so
like you can see that like that's not
yeah like that's not really like a query
string like you can say
name
is bastion and let's say and let's see
what happens now
same thing
because um string is not the right type
for these types of
like
yeah like requests and for this we can
use a hashmap so
we can use
the hashmap from the standard library
collections
and we can say
we expect a hashmap
with string and string
and the beauty of rust is now that it
tells us hey that's the wrong type here
so here like we can't make a mistake
we have to expect a hashmap here
and obviously we can't print it out like
this
because
we didn't implement uh yeah like a
display trade for the hashmap
so
we can use the debug trade
and print out our
mcquery the parameters
we can try this again now
and now
we get back our
our
our um
mcquery
the parameters so this is like the
difference
between like a parameter or like a yeah
like a query string in warp and this is
how you would
basically create apis
yeah
like maybe
you have a product
and you want to query like the product
name
you